if I'm an unproduced writer Gina how do
I get in front of these people how do I
use my story well the single best way in
my opinion for a young writer to get
seen is to write a play and if you have
talent and you you know you can write a
play and cast unknowns and there's so
many hungry young talented actors you
know to put in your play and if you are
if you have the talent it's gonna show
you know and and people will come and
word-of-mouth is gonna say oh you got to
see that play and then you know because
the thing that's great about theatre
aside from everything theatre is just
it's the purest but the writer rules and
you know if the writer wants whatever
the writer writes it no one can change a
word and you know everybody in Hollywood
knows if you write a script by the time
the shooting script comes who knows
who's been on it you know what I mean
like you know 20 writers could have been
on there and between your original
script and the shooting script but with
a play whoever wrote that play whoever
penned it is gonna get the credit and
you don't need anybody's approval for
the play up you know I mean you just I
mean of course you'd be lucky if you can
get one of them you know the great small
houses like the Odyssey or something to
produce it but if not you can put it up
anywhere and get people there and you
know it's not expensive that to me is I
think the number one way the other
things that the young writer if that if
they don't a want to do that or now for
whatever reason hey theater whatever
they need to be around other people you
know like people I've gotten letters
from people saying I live in South
Dakota can i still stay here and no you
cannot you know if I have to live here
you have to live here like you know and
I love it here but I'm saying you know
it's hard enough to crack the mystery
wall you know you haven't do it from
North Dakota you're not you're not going
to do it you know maybe you can move
there after your Hugh
I don't know but you know I don't know
where some of the greats live but when
you're building your career you have to
be here
you